Понад 9 тисяч підтверджених випадків інфікування новим коронавірусом в Україні.
Однак це лише верхівка айсберга.
"Тіньова" захворюваність більша,
і справжню картину епідемії можна зрозуміти, лише збільшивши кількість тестувань на Covid-19.
Таким є зараз постулат вірусологів, зокрема, у Німеччині.
Але в Україні такі тести пройшли дуже мало людей.
Набагато менше, ніж, наприклад, у Німеччині, де ситуацію вже взято під контроль.
Та ніж у сусідніх Польщі, Росії та Білорусі.
За даними ресурсу Our World in Data,
у Німеччині станом на 28 квітня провели понад 2 мільйони тестувань.
В результаті було виявлено понад 150 тисяч випадків нового коронавірусу.
Кожне тестування коштує понад 100 євро.
Безкоштовно пройти тест у Німеччині можуть люди з ознаками гострої вірусної інфекції
або ті, хто контактував із носіями covid-інфекції.
Завдяки масовому тестуванню німцям вдалося ізолювати прихованих носіїв коронавірусу
та вже у квітні взяти епідемію під контроль.
Лідером за кількістю і хворих, і проведених тестувань є Сполучені Штати.
Водночас нещодавно вийшла на друге місце за кількістю тестувань Російська Федерація.
28 квітня тут, за російськими офіційними даними, .
відбулося понад 3 мільйони тестувань і виявлено 81 тисячу інфікованих
Хоча ще у лютому та березні лікарі у Росії часто відмовляли бажаючим у тестуваннях,
згодом держава зобов'язала тестувати певні категорії населення.
Західна сусідка України провела вже більше 300 тисяч перевірок на коронавірус.
Поки розмах епідемії тут схожий на український - понад 11 тисяч інфікованих.
Проте летальність є відносно вищою, ніж в Україні - 535 смертей.
Як і у багатьох інших країнах, медики тут часто не прописують тестів у разі симптомів.
Припускають, що реальна захворюваність - набагато вища.
Приблизно таку ж кількість заражень Covid-19 зафіксували білоруси.
Однак закрита інформаційна політика цієї країни та відсутність незалежних ЗМІ
не дозволяють довіряти цим офіційним даним.
Зокрема, викликає сумнів оглядачів те, що у Білорусі лише 10 тисяч інфікованих
та 72 померлих від коронавірусу.
Україна, доки не привезли імпортні тести, за кількістю тестувань довгий час посідала
одну з останніх сходинок у світі.
До 10 квітня в Україні встигли провести лише 32 з половиною тисячі тестувань.
Це мізерна кількість для 42-мільйонної країни.
Тож, насправді, зважаючи на цупкість нового коронавірусу,
кількість інфекцій може бути у рази більшою, ніж офіційні 9 тисяч виявлених випадків.
На сьомому тижні карантину в Україні почали тестувати по 5 тисяч осіб на день.
Як очікує МОЗ, незабаром буде проводитись від 8 до 10 тисяч тестувань
щодня надійним ПЛР-методом.
Дефіцит тестувань був пов'язаний із тим, що тестових наборів спершу було дуже мало.
У березні їх за розпорядженням президента Зеленського
імпортували з Китаю та Південної Кореї.
Однак у середині квітня держава закупила велику партію тестів українських виробників.
Ці ПЛР-тести виробляє компанія "Українські генетичні технології",
яку заснували колишні учасники АТО з добровольчого батальйону "Айдар".
Ще два зареєстрованих виробники ПЛР-систем в Україні -
Інститут молекулярної біології і генетики НАН та фірма Diagen.
Скільки коштує одна тест-система, не розголошується.
У МОЗ кажуть про збій алгоритмів доставки зразків.
Пацієнти скаржились на те, що лікарі відмовляли їм у проходженні тестів
навіть за наявності симптомів коронавірусу -
сильного кашлю, температури, головного болю та неприємних відчуттів у гортані та легенях.
Слід зауважити, що на сайті українського МОЗу
і зараз важко знайти інформацію про те, кому і де та за якими критеріями
можна пройти вірусний тест.
В Україні направлення на тест має дати сімейний лікар або швидка допомога.
За протоколом МОЗ, для цього людина повинна матиознаки гострого вірусного захворювання
або ж контактувати з підтвердженим носієм коронавірусної інфекції у той чи інший спосіб.
З минулого тижня тести дозволено проходити усім медпрацівникам.
Щоправда приватні лікарні тестують і без направлення,
але один тест може коштувати пацієнту до кількох тисяч гривень.
У європейських країнах тестують навіть без симптомів.
Відкрито додаткові мобільні пункти тестування.
В Україні таких пунктів немає.
В Україні наразі вирішується, чи запровадити ІФА-тестування,
які дозволяють розпізнати наявність імунітету від коронавірусної інфекції.
Тобто, встановити, чи людина вже латентно перехворіла на Covid-19.
І таким чином дізнатись реальний станепідемії.